KIND OATTACKDON'T YOU TELL US W
E E SEEING.
>> Repor
JOHN, HE ON THE NORTHERN
WEST
'RE SEEINGOP AVY BOMBART NOFON
FLM THIS AREA.
IF WE PAN OV HERE,Y
OTT  CAN
SHOW.E TH CONNECTS
URPIN TO CENTR KS
DESTROYED.
IT WAS BY UKRAINIAN
RUSSIAN FORCNTRAT WHATE SEEING I
NA AND
SAFELY.FOO DESTROYEDIDR TO GET
NOW, SINCE WE'VE BEE, WE HEARD
ERTHAT
ALS
ARE.AN IMIN HOW
MANY OF THEM PINNED U CAN SE HEN
WE HAVE SEEN LOTF PEOPLE WHO
ARE ELDERLY,PE WHO
PEE THEYE BEENINARDMENT EING A N
FOR DAYSD AND AROW TO LL, ITUSTY
.
P COMING, TRYING TO
CROSS THE BRIDGE.U CAN SEE'WATE
FLOWING THROUGH ITTOK ACROSS AT
FROM WHES
ORIGINALLY DOWTHIS THE P
NO JOHN, IE ONLY WAY TO
AND IT IS RELATIVEUR TER IS BEI
AS THETS
PICKING UP OT ITA STEADY STR ATG
IN, CLARISSA, IT'SENIT.
E AN E
E ARE THEY
TRYING TO  AND THEUNIFORM HELPI
THOSLE HELPING
THE PEOPLE
UKRAINIAN MILITARY, AND THEY'RE
OBVIOUSLY WANTING US TO STAY A
OUTE WAY HERE 'T
OBSTRUCT IN ANY WAY,PE, OR
T PASSAGE, THFE
PEOPLE.
IT DOEOKBRHING
IT MAY BE A DY.
E NORELY
WEFU NOT SW YOU
ANYTHING THAT MIGHT BE
GRHIOR TOOISTURBING.
BUT, LISTEN, THIS ISAND
THIS ITH IS ALH TRUISM.
'SOME A CLICT IT'SSO WAR. IS IN
THE BRUNT OFI THINK ASSE PEOPL H
L TOAP RELATIVE SAFETY OF CITY'N
AS YOU POINTED OUT, NOBODY KNOW
ENCROACHING ON ALL
WE SAW A VILLAGE IN THEST OF KT
YI YESTE.AL
INBECAUSE IT
HEANS POTENTIALLTH
YOU CAN SEW ALSOLDIERSG TOR THI.
IT LOOKSON
ORT OF MAKESHIFT
AN EXTRINARY SCENE OFBRAVERY,
Y RALLYING TOGET
DI WITH WHATEVER
THEYY N,
>> CLARISSA, IYOU CAN, IYOU'RE O
ITH US ATLE LONG.JUSTEAHUDS IN
I CAN'T HEAR TRYTHERE.
UR AUDIENCE, I WDOND AREDISTURB
PEOP OE NOW.
THEY ARE SUFFERING SO BADLY,
ISSA, JUST FROM A MILITARY
WE KNOW THERE HAD EAA HUTA
VLENSKYY, THE
PRESIDENT YS
ELDERLY, THE CHIUTOF THE CITIES
FIGHT.
A CONCERN AMO F SAFETY
MAKES THESN MORE OF A TARGET?
RL,
EO
DI CENTER OF
KEEFE -- A LEM, SAY, JOHRE HEAN
TO THE TRAIN STATION.
WE WERE AT THE S
PEOPLE WE TRYING S
TRAINS.
NOW IT'S MUCH MOREEDLOT MORERAF
TRTRYINGR WEST IS TH PORT OF
CALLWHAT'S EXTRAORDINARY, JOHN,
BORN OUT HERE BYR OF
PEOPLE STILLINRAIGHT
BOMBARDMENT IS APEOPLE T LEYET.
HEAD AROUND THE EA
DESERTING THEIR LI
FAMILIES, THEIR IR
PETS, THR HOUSESHING
AN IT'S EXTRAORDARY TOEEWHAT IN
THESLE HAVE BEEN UNDER HEY'RE VR
DAYS A AR EYING THEM THEY'RE
THEMLEDGE
BA.YOU CAE MANY O
ELDERLY
.
PEOPLE ARE SO EXHAUSTED THEY
RE WAL TTHIS
F TWISTED METAL., AS SEE,
ARE ELDERLY.SS.USAW
LUCKYM O HELP HER CARRY
EXCUSE ME, WE TRO LELYD BY THE
ATION.
FR
THEY'RE EXUS
TH'V THEY
YOU'RE RIGHT, YOU KNOW, YOD MEE
ABOU GOINGTH.LOT OFHESE PEOPLE A
A WH KNOW THEY'RATTY ONCE THEY H
G TO GO, W
G TO S
THEY CAN OF THEIANY IDEA WHE
BELONGINGSBACKL HEARING EA OF LJ
IT'ST GOINP GETTG OS.  THE FACE
COURAGE, THE FACES OF FFTHFA WA.
WWATCH THIS
ISOW O BEHIND ERE
CLE CLOSING INIV? THES ARE GETTN
SY
THIS.
WHA'RE SEEING AROU.S.FFS THAT
THE PUSH H NOT GONE WA RHOPED.Y
I LINK UP TROS ANLAUNCH AN AN
OFTHE UKRAINIAN ITIES ARE
YINGSIN THEY'V
ANATLIAN HOSTAGES ANN SEMENTY TA